hi my name is Rhett Elaine Brett is a
physics professor at Southeastern
Louisiana University today I'll be
breaking down amazing feats of physics
from superheroes in movies and
television superhero landing Deadpool
landing that's really hard on your knees
you know one of the great things about
Deadpool both in the comics and in the
movies is that he breaks the fourth wall
and interacts with the audience I know
right in this case he talks about the
superhero landing superhero landing
superhero wait for it the idea is a
superhero lands with one knee one fist
and a foot on the ground so three
contact points but it's a very sudden
move it's not like a normal landing it
does look really cool and I think
happens all the time
[Music]
and is that better than the way a normal
person would hit the ground the answer
is no that's really hard on your knees
totally impractical they all do so you
got to think about the forces acting on
a person while they're landing from
falling from somewhere the key is to
have the force as small as possible one
way to do that is to increase the
distance over which you stop so if I
jump and land on the ground I let my
knees Bend and my center of mass moves
down while my knees Bend increase the
distance over which I stop and decreases
the force there's a thing called a
parachute landing fall and you don't
even stand up you hit you bend down you
roll over on the ground and you increase
the distance over which you stop even
more that's the best way to do it the
superhero landing it's just gonna be a
bad idea we all know how this turns out
kinetic energy black panther
kinetic energy is a quantity you can use
to describe objects in motion we have
momentum which is mass times velocity
and then there's kinetic energy which is
one-half mass velocity squared
you know kinetic energy isn't a real
thing it's a way to view nature it's a
way to view interactions so anything
that's moving would have kinetic energy
if I take a baseball and I throw it it's
moving it has mass so it has kinetic
energy black panther suit
somehow has an interaction between the
bullet and his suit to take the kinetic
energy of the bullets and store it in
some type of internal battery and then
once he has enough energy stored up he
can release it in a energy pull of some
type to do whatever he wants I'm not
sure exactly how it works that's what
makes him Black Panther and the
technology of Wakanda is beyond me to
fully understand recoil wonder why
[Music]
so what is recoil suppose I am standing
on a frozen lake and I have a basketball
or some heavy weighted ball and I throw
the ball well the ball's momentum is
gonna change because I exert a force on
it but the ball pushes back on me with
the same force so I'm gonna have the
exact same change momentum that's gonna
make me move back course it makes
complete sense this is the idea of
recoil when you throw something one way
you go back the other way so a bullet
has momentum it's moving it has mass it
has but it turns out that it's moving
really fast but it has pretty low mass
and it doesn't have that much momentum
if you collide a bullet with a bracelet
or a person in some way then that person
would have to recoil with the same
momentum but the person has such a large
mass the recoil velocity would be super
tiny and so you don't really get recoil
from normal bullets when they hit people
so in this case Wonder Woman deflecting
a bullet it should be fine is there
anything else you wanna show me contact
area Justice League I'll take the ones
on the right
the Superman building things impossible
forget about the flying forget about the
super-strength even with that he
couldn't do this so imagine you had a
jello cake it's like a big blob of
jell-o this big is this a bad time to
bring up my blood sugar and you wouldn't
lift up the jello with a toothpick by
pushing on the bottom the toothpick
would just go right through the jello on
top of that the jello would probably
break in half too so both of those
things are a problem Superman's pushing
in the middle of the building trying to
support the whole thing he would just
poke right through the whole thing and
the building would fall if he wants to
actually lift the building he needs to
increase the contact area either get
bigger hands which that's probably not
gonna happen or he could possibly have
some cables that attach to multiple
locations on the building and then lift
it from the top maybe it doesn't look as
cool but it'd be more plausible at least
weird and so many ways strength
spider-man homecoming
at the beginning spider-man uses his
webs to connect one side of the boat to
the other in an attempt to prevent it
from falling apart and it doesn't work
[Applause]
it could be any number of reasons
particularly he just doesn't have enough
webs to actually exert enough force
between the two halves to prevent them
from falling apart the ultimate tensile
strength the point at which the tension
breaks were the string breaks for
spider-man's webs I mean you'd first
need to know what's made of and then you
need to know the diameter of it it's
really difficult to estimate how much
that could be a better way to approach
this would be to calculate the tension
that he exerts on the boat when it
breaks the the more they lean the
greater the gravitational force is on
that piece to pull it apart and you need
a lot of force to keep these two things
together and maybe his webs just aren't
strong enough to do that
great job Peter
I suspect the 98% means that the total
force needed to keep one side of the
boat up is 98 percent of what you need
to prevent it from falling over if the
force isn't great enough the boat tilts
and it stretches that web and eventually
the web breaks and then you have no
force from the web and that makes more
webs break and have a sort of cascading
failure hi spider-man band practice
[Applause]
the Ironman suit may be more successful
at pushing the boat back together for a
couple of reasons number one it's
possible that his mini micro thruster
rockets that attach to the side of the
ship are just stronger than spider-man
twelves the second big thing is that
those forces can keep moving as the boat
moves
whereas spider-man's force is a static
force once you stretch a pass out it
can't it can't pull it back together it
just prevents it from falling apart
further the ship floats because it
prevents water from getting inside and
makes it overall effective didn't see
less than water once you violate the
integrity of the hull game's over that
thing's is gonna sink really fast
I don't think spider-man's gonna have
enough time to push it back together I
don't think Ironman is gonna have enough
time to push it back together now it's
just a movie so we're okay with that
what do you want me to do I think you've
done enough
terminal velocity Captain America the
Winter Soldier
see where to parachute
no he was
[Music]
so when Captain America jumps out of the
plane there's really two forces that
come into play the first is the
gravitational force that pulls him down
but there's another force as he starts
to fall an increase in speed there's an
air resistance force he's colliding with
the air molecules and those air
molecules push back on him in the
opposite direction that he's moving and
in fact it gets to the part where it is
the same as the gravitational force now
he has an upward pushing force in a
downward pushing force that are equal
magnitude with equal magnitude forces he
moves at a constant speed we call this
terminal velocity because he doesn't get
any faster when Captain America first
leaves the plane he starts off in a
standard skydiving position this
position allows the largest surface area
for the highest air resistant force and
therefore the lowest terminal velocity
it also allows you to move your hands in
a way that you could actually control
your motion by pushing the air in
different directions towards the end of
the jump he actually goes into a more
vertical position this decreases the
surface area that collides with the air
and makes him fall even faster he wants
to hit the water feet first so he flips
over hits the water feet first in like a
pencil dive or pencil jump and the nice
thing about the feet first vertical
position when hitting the water is that
it will make him penetrate the deepest
into the water which increases the
distance of where tree stops and
decreases the stopping force and gives
them a better chance of surviving I mean
it's Captain America so these programs
survive no matter what net force Iron
Man 3
see that guy I'm gonna swing by are you
just gonna grab I'll Electrify your arm
you won't be able to open your hand we
can do this Heather
once you start having multiple people in
a chain hanging together the person on
the bottom they're just hanging like a
normal person
the next person has to pull with the
force equal to their own weight and the
force of the person pulling down below
them which is their weight the third
person has to pull with the force of
three people and you can see it starts
getting really large and uncontrollable
Ironman wants to solve this problem by
essentially electrically shocking their
muscles into contracting so they can't
let go
I'll Electrify your arm you won't be
able to open your hand I don't think
that would work for a number of reasons
I get a lot of this it's okay first if
you get like five people in a line it's
probably not just about muscles things
start to break in human arms and it
wouldn't work the second thing is that
you can have an electrical shock make
people's muscles contract but the
problem is that you normally need a
closed circuit you need a path for the
current to go there and all the way back
and he just has a chain there's no way
for the current to get back to Iron Man
and use of power supply to force this
shock gripping nice work guys
good team effort all around go us miss
integration the boys when you ever so a
trains running really quick and he runs
into the girl what would really happen I
mean it's such a hard question because
it really depends on a train it is he
invincible or is he like just a really
fast normal human if he's a really fast
normal human colliding with a stationary
human they would both have the same
amount of damage because if he pushes on
her with the forest she pushes back with
the same force so whatever happened to
her would happen to him in the clip she
just turns into goo so clearly he has
some other powers other than just being
super fast would he just push right
through or would which she recoil well
it really depends on again how fast he's
going and how he actually hits her one
part of him hits her before the rest of
him does he could essentially poke
through her I know that's kind of gross
and once he's done that he he kind of
disables the integrity of her body such
that it's possible she could go splatter
it all over the place
Oh watching that clip there is one issue
that that is weird if he's running this
way and hits her why does some of the
blood go back on on her boyfriend if it
appears that he hitting her would push
all the blood in the same direction he
was moving so I mean it's kind of a
gross clip but it shows an important
point in the story and that the super
heroes aren't always nice guys
right running on water be Incredibles
[Music]
so let's say you want to run on water
you need an upward force to counteract
the gravitational force that pushes down
one way to do this would be kind of like
slapping the water if I hit the water
with my hand or foot then the water
pushes up on me but it's not a huge
force and it doesn't last for very long
I don't know I don't know how he does it
that means that you have to hit the
water really hard and then hit it again
really hard so you've really got to move
your feet back and forth super quick in
order to get this whole thing to work
you must have been booking how fast you
think you were Holly man I don't think a
normal person can do it but clearly -
can do it
[Music]
so when he stops and kind just hovers
there for a little bit on the water I
think it's the wily coyote effect so if
you remember wily coyote would chase the
roadrunner
he'd golf a cliff and then he'd say well
I just realized I'm now on the ground
and then he falls it's very dramatic and
it's kind of funny and I think that's
exactly what happens with - of course as
soon as he stops he would start sinking
into the water and fall down but it's
its comedic effect what are you waiting
for
[Music]
blind Ironman ready and three two
in this scene Tony Stark is testing out
his Iron Man suit he had built one
before but it wasn't as sophisticated as
this one so he needs to make sure the
thrusters are configured properly to
allow him to fly so imagine you had like
a pencil and you want to hold it on your
hand right here and you're holding it
from the bottom if you push up it's very
easily just gonna tip over
and and so rockets from the bottom of a
device are a little problematic real
Rockets do this by having dimples on the
thrusters that can change the direction
very easily but there's another solution
and that's to have a higher thruster and
that's what Ironman does with this hand
when his hands are higher up then the
thrust is above the center mass and it
makes it much more stable and on top of
that he has his hand further apart from
his body and that further increases
stability in fact there's a guy that has
real-life Iron Man suit type flying and
he uses jets on his hands and it's much
more stable than putting them on your
feet so this is exactly how I would do
it if I was gonna do it impact force
guardians of the galaxy
[Music]
I'm not sure what exactly Groot does in
this case but if he stays completely
rigid as a rigid sphere then it's not
really going to help people inside now
if he has some type of I don't know in a
car we call it a crumple zone where the
car actually changes dimensions and
crumples up during a collision this
would increase the distance over which
it stops which would decrease
acceleration and it would make it more
survivable for the people inside another
aspect of this cage idea could be one to
protect from things like debris that
gets thrown around during the crash that
would definitely work I mean if you have
a shell around you and something comes
flying in that shell could block it it's
not just that you want wood to be strong
you definitely want it to be flexible
drew maybe he's like can pick maybe he
can pick what kind of wood he grows into
so he could make it both flexible and
strong depending on the situation
thank you see hoots the only one of you
who has a clue if I was Groot which I am
clearly not Groot I would have liked
things go down below the sphere that you
couldn't see and have those impact with
the ground first and have them kind of
be your crumple zone and then keep the
sphere rigid to protect from debris and
then you'd have a rigid part as a sphere
and then a springy part below for spares
the defenders
so in this scene from the defenders we
have Jessica Jones super strong and Luke
Cage super strong and when they punch
they really would have to consider what
angle they push at if I push with some
super large force then that same force
that can be applied to me because forces
come in pairs forces are always an
interaction between two objects so if I
punch horizontally the person could go
flying across the room but I'd go flying
back the other way and that may be
effective but it wouldn't look cool
there's a better way to punch if I was a
super-powered puncher and I punched up
then that person would push down on me
and I would get pushed into the floor
but I would not get pushed back so if
you're a super-powered person you can't
just go around punching like a normal
person you have to think about the
consequences of your actions but we
should probably all do that anyway just
look how you been I'm sorry x-ray vision
Man of Steel
[Music]
so this is the part where Clark Kent
starts to realize that he has powers and
one of those powers is x-ray vision
how does x-ray vision work I think the
first question is how does vision work
we see things because light reflects off
of them and enters our eye or maybe it's
a it's a light source itself but light
has to enter your eye in order to see
things x-rays are just another type of
light with that smaller wavelength than
visible light but in this case how does
Superman have x-ray vision is stuff
coming out of his eyes or stuff coming
into his eyes if x-rays are coming out
of his eyes he can't see them it's just
shooting out there are x-rays around
background radiation it's not very much
and that could pass through people's
bodies and he could see them but overall
it's definitely a problematic thing to
be able to see through people with just
rising wind up Avengers endgame
[Music]
so Captain America has Thor's hammer and
he's trying to hit Thanos he could just
hold the hammer and swing his whole arm
and hit him but by winding up the hammer
first it's going in a circular motion
the hammer is actually going at a
greater speed if he times just right his
arms moving up and the Hammers moving up
relative to the hand so that gives it a
much greater speed on impact with Thanos
his head so greater impact speed would
mean a greater impact force and
hopefully knock him down in this case
there's no real benefit to spinning at
multiple times except for the main
benefit that it looks cool and if you're
a superhero and you're in you know a big
battle number one you got to look cool
give me that conclusion I think these
are just great examples of even if
they're not real physics physics is
still all around us and we can find it
in the most trivial things even
superhero movies so physics in movies
I'm all for it even if it's not 100
percent correct because what if you did
have completely realistic physics and
superhero movies it might not be that
much fun we go to the movies now for the
correct physics we go there because they
don't have correct physics really and
and I'm fine with that